thank you hey no worries give me ability
to stand out of the light up here okay
why don't we why don't we go go ahead
and get started welcome everyone this is
our the usual Thursday noon research
conference of the department of medical
informatics and clinical epidemiology
and I look around and X I see some old
faces but I also see a bunch of faces I
don't know which is a good thing it
means we've gotten the word out and have
gotten a lot from around campus to to
show up in addition to being our regular
research conference this is also one in
a series of a new initiative that we've
undertaken in the department that some
of you know about called the informatics
discovery lab and the goal of this
initiative is to try to build
partnerships with organizations that are
outside the usual academic sphere at
least for us certainly not other
universities but and the big part of
that partnership is with industry and so
we've reached out to a number of
industry partnerships and we've happened
to been delighted to discover that IBM
exists in our own backyard even though
as our speaker will talk about it's
truly a global and virtual company but
there are some people who actually live
in Oregon and one of those is our
speaker today Steve Miller who is
program director of IBM's information
management practitioner marketing team
and so he's responsible for their big
data and analytics professional of the
future program which I know that at
least those of you in the room who are
students in our informatics program are
thinking about your future as data and
information professionals this program
that Steve leads collaborates with
universities around the US and the world
to develop the strong pipeline of talent
for the next century with the focus on
data scientists information architects
and strategists data policy
professionals developers and infirmity
shins I actually added that last one um
it wasn't on the form here but anyways
um so Steve's going to tell us what what
we what those of you who are students
need to know about data and what those
of us who are faculty need to know about
so we can best educate you and those who
follow you so I will turn it over to
sign well thank you all right so I just
like kind curious who the audience is so
how many people here are undergrads I
didn't see a lot of hands so everybody
everyone else it's a student is in its
in a graduate program and the rest of
you are faculty or other roles research
researchers oak business systems analyst
all right cool all right well thank you
all right so as he said I'm from IBM and
I happened live in Portland Ore actually
beaverton but I make us my home and I
lived here since 98 and absolutely love
it would take a lot to get me out of
Oregon because I think this is a really
a fantastic place to live so I'm here
today to talk about some work that I've
been doing around a broader set of
careers around data and I don't have a
lot of specifics around health
informatics actually have kind of an
empty slide that maybe we could work on
together to fill in god because i'm
learning from your your faculty here
today so let's move to the first slide
so how many people here have heard about
the term data science or data scientist
most most times right and there's a one
of my favorite uh was this a Harvard
Business Review article the sexiest job
right of the 21st century right I think
that's a pretty cool idea and because
this is a new role its emerging in a lot
of ways it's not any different from what
you're studying here to school it's just
a more general application of it and
it's a job that's growing yeah this is
indeed comdata so if you've ever used
indeed com as a job hunting
there's a trends on the first page you
can click of the trends and you can type
in keywords that'll show you you know
what is the trend of that keyword
showing up in job applicant job postings
and for whatever reason it always tends
to trend down at the end of the year for
so you always see these word I don't
maybe it's just the way jobs get posted
during the year but you can see that
it's a pretty solid percentage growth
rate right times almost a hundred
percent growth over the previous time so
it's a fast growing but i'm going to
show you one coming up that is much much
faster growing than this right now this
may grow faster in the future but right
now it's growing very healthy it's a new
career field and we're finding that so
far there's only a handful of schools in
the country that claim to have a program
to create data scientists not that they
don't already exist under other names
but this is a new name and new concept
to a lot of people and it requires a bit
different thinking about what does it
mean to be a data scientist what are the
skills I'll have a slide coming up and
the lit books are going into a little
bit about what are the types of skills
that a day at scientist needs let's go
to the next slide so here's another one
here the growth rates much more
significant it right this is the
emerging role of the chief data officer
and you may think well I've got a CIO
isn't that a chief data officer and the
answer is no right so a chief data
officer is actually focused on all
things data what are we going to do
strategically with our data in our
company to make our company more
competitive and some companies are
architecting their entire business model
around data so I imagine everyone in
here is used yelp or used tripadvisor or
use all these wear these these are
companies are based on data that's
curated by their customers and they just
provide an engine to do that that's
their business model right they'll sell
advertising other things around it but
it's the data all right I'm a big
Foursquare user again I'm self curating
all the day that goes into foursquare
and so I'm pretty people in here that
using other similar types of sites right
there's one called untapped I'm a beer
drinker
so with untapped I can enter the beers
that I drink I can check in to him I can
share with my beer fans alright this is
just the beginning right it's integrated
with Foursquare it's integrated with
facebook I can post it and share it
everywhere there's a whole new thinking
do a lot of things about data and the
pervasiveness of data and then these new
concepts of quote big data that are
causing companies and government
organizations and individuals to think
differently about it in ways that we've
never had to really consider before it
was something that some some geeks in
the IT office took care of but now it's
something that actually affects
everybody and that's a really important
point that I really want to make in
today's talk that data really does
affect all of us and there's actually a
core what I call literacy around data
that everybody needs to have just you
start thinking about your personal data
that you're putting on linkedin or
you're putting on your facebook page or
twitter right and how you manage and
present yourself to the world that's a
form of data right and your reputation
is kind of built into that and it's what
causing all of us to rethink this and
there's companies out there IBM included
that are using all the information that
we're voluntarily putting on to these
sites to make business decisions so
companies are understanding like there's
there's companies out there there's
focused on like apparel and they want to
figure out so how do i need to have next
year's next quarters fashions figure it
out what what what should i do right and
so they can start looking at people's
Twitter feeds and make smarter decisions
it faster about what they need to do
differently with their product line just
based on all the data that you're all
curating for it it's really up to them
to figure out how best to do that and
get it right and there's also cases in
the healthcare world I believe where I
think that anybody else to read this one
I hadn't delved too deeply into this
story but there's actually some studies
done where they're using Twitter feeds
local public health officials are able
to find out faster whether there's a flu
outbreak in their city all right that's
pretty cool right so data is just
changing everything and that's why you
have this need for new job roles it may
be at a higher title not be not somebody
hidden in the company that's going to go
do this for everybody and why you need a
chief data officer for example that's
sitting on the corporate board next to
the CIO the CFO the CIO is managing now
everything everything networked together
does a phizzer a laptop on everybody's
desk and so forth but taking a strategic
look and you can see the the growth path
here two hundred percent in recent
quarters right that's pretty significant
so far much faster than data scientist
so data scientist may completely
surprised us and grow even faster over
time as it grows from beyond its the
current fad were the moment is something
that everybody's actually doing next
slide all right so here's a surprise
data policy job is actually the fastest
growing data role by a wide margin and
I'll explain what I mean by data policy
in a minute if you start looking at this
so here's the data governance Oh jobs
that have data and the government of the
data somewhere in that job description
six hundred percent job growth look this
one data steward fifteen hundred percent
job growth who knew I didn't even know
till I went looked at these data right
and the interesting thing is try to find
a school that's teaching this and any
really concerted way and it's really
hard to find that but yet this is where
the jobs are and and this is why are
these jobs here everybody whether you're
working for a government whether you're
working for a private company is d has
to deal with how am I going to manage
this data who's going to get access to
it how are they going to get access to
it in my compliance with local laws and
regulations federal laws and regulations
do I have a privacy policy am I obeying
that privacy policy right this is a huge
time sink for companies and they're out
looking for skill everywhere
hiring people and training them
themselves because nobody's yet at this
point is teaching this in any concerted
way now I don't want to take away from
the schools like the Syracuse I school
that do you have a sliver of their
program focus on some of these things
but they're not really focused yet on
these broader issues and one of the
things that I've been doing working with
schools are going hey you want to create
the first data policy program in the
country partner with IBM right so maybe
OHS you can do that yeah so this is
because this is the embarrassment often
happens around doing this wrong so a
gentleman I just met actually lives in
Portland wrote a book on the ethics of
big data court Davis and I read his book
and I found his email address go wow he
lives here in Portland's we met for a
beard now I'm actually going to bring
him to our conference in November the
teacher tutorial on how to handle big
data ethically how do we manage that as
a organization so we actually have a
structure around that and try not to
embarrass ourselves as embarrassing
yourself is remarkably easy in ways you
might not expect so how many people
heard about target last year giving
themselves in a lot of hot water
publicly because they made it aware that
they were offering women things based on
the fact that they figured out they were
pregnant based on what they were buying
right oops right because that's maybe
you didn't want to do that maybe you
needed to think about what would be the
negative reactions of us making taking
those types of business choices and
that's just I think this the beginning I
think that's why this area is actually
going to continue to be the fastest
growing area because every company
impact says right in some cases you can
date a scientist I we can go subcontract
that out bring somebody in to help us
figure it out or we can hire a use of
all these startups kingdai Oh blah blah
blah blah blah there's a thousand
startups I'll giving data science
services in the cloud but at the end of
the day you can't really outsource data
policy you got to do it yourself all
right next
so this one is a little bit too wordy
for the bigger room so but I but the key
idea here is that data skills are needed
everywhere and doesn't matter what
you're studying you need to know about
data you need to have some core
analytical skills because every job the
future is going to require some core
literacy into those ideas and we're
already seeing specialties come out
there's lawyers there's actual practices
now that are emerging that a focus on
data law they're not very many of them
but I think as all this continues to
accelerate we're going to see a lot more
specialization and things like data law
open data and government so Portland is
one of on the forefront of open data in
government and there's going to be on
june first a hackathon in the city here
that sponsored at Thetas corporation a
small company in the pearl actually not
in the pearl old town and i participated
in this last year i'm hoping to be there
again and the whole idea is what cool
things can we do with open data Oh
government data build apps do things
with it fun right so hopefully we see
some of you volunteering for that one
and if you want out giving my twitter ID
and you can ping me later and what is it
in my stream of my twitter is how to
sign up for the hackathon so business
schools probably the fastest adoption is
amazing it's hard to find a business
school in the country that's claiming
not to have an analytics program so I
don't think we're going to have any
shortage of business people with Anna
with core analytic skills the real
shortage is going to come in the skills
everywhere else but there are programs
like here on the health informatics I'd
that are going to fill that need but
it's the other all the other fields are
going to need competency of day how do I
work with data how do I analyze it how
do I apply machine learning how do I
visualize it how do i do all these
things with data where are those skills
going to come from for those fields
right that's really the big challenge
for us right now
and that literacy piece is something I
think is really important and so data
literacy and analytics literacy and
that's a decision I think schools are
going to have to start making are we
going to have how should we structure
that one idea I have is that maybe you
should have a course for during every
year of your four year undergrad and it
as you progress it gets deeper so your
first year it's a basic core literacy
and what how information systems work
and how do you interact with social and
how does that impact the next year maybe
it's a more focused course on analytics
probably the basics right you got to
learn a little bit about before you can
go to the next level analytics you got
out understand statistics and
probability and some of these core
pieces your junior year it's more
focused analytics and your senior year
it's probably something tied directly to
your field how do i apply analytics to
the field that I'm studying so that
would that could easily be four courses
but that's not easy to change in a lot
of school systems add if you're going to
add four required courses for every
student to take what comes out right
that's a big challenge for faculty
members all around the world and then
today I was learning about health
informatics here at ohsu it's an area I
personally have not spent a lot of time
on so I'm learning from you today and I
think that we're going to see not just
bio or health informatics I think these
are going to emerge and pretty much
every field over time and I think would
be interesting if we could just maybe do
some prediction software to figure out
where we'll be yeah the next two or
three of these specialized informatics
types of programs starting to crop up
around specific fields FC all right so
any questions at this point
push just for people who ask questions
okay I'm just slide here you have data
literacy and analytics literacy i think
i have a kind of vague idea of what the
differences but could you verbalize it
for us sure data is just really the
underlying two pieces of information
about how do we manage the data itself
so it could be a simple that's
understanding the data is going to be on
your phone let's go or it is going to be
on your computer or in some cloud server
and understanding the ramifications of
all of that without actually even
thinking about analyzing it right all of
us are going to wrestling with that
every day and making choices about it
sometimes good sometimes bad for example
I'm a big Evernote user and I was just
thinking last night gee why isn't there
a pay app in on my Evernote somebody
grabbed my iPad they could be looking
through some stuff they probably
shouldn't be seen and then okay oh
they're charging for that so I have to
go pay for that but that's another
element of data and the security of data
and how you manage all that that I think
is going to be important to everybody
whether it's your individual or whether
it's their organizations are you working
for organizations you're volunteering
for your government all of that about
how this data is managed and shared it's
something we all need to have a
fundamental understanding of how that
works whereas analytics is much more
focused on a lot of other concepts ok
now we that data is there not what do I
do with that how do I think about it how
can I pretty make predictions from it
kinda outta mate decisions decisive or
decision analytics is an emerging field
a lot of companies are automating that
making decisions on the fly oftentimes
when you go do a loan application these
days they're making a decision for you
like that but there's a lot of math and
a lot of an things are in the background
there that all fed into them being able
to do that and I think that's going to
happen probably in health care as well a
lot of decisions
made by the software and when do you
have to decide oh the softer can't make
this decision and we got to have a
doctor come in to validate that that's
the right choice it means a lot we don't
know yet but decision analytics is a
huge burgeoning new area so if you're
going to answer this question later I
guess you can skip but I'm this might
appear a bit pointed I'm guess I'm
curious what is IBM hope to get out of
pushing this data literacy and an
understanding of data stewardship um
well I think it's really quite simple
any time a corporation is pushing
anything like this there is a
fundamental belief that we will profit
as a company in the long run right but
also iBM has a different view on a lot
of things that there actually is a
societal benefit to a lot of things so
we have this how many people have heard
about IBM smarter planet advertising or
any news about smarter planet we're
making a lot of investments in cases
where we walk into a city with a team of
IBM verse at no charge for the city to
help them wrestle with a local issue
which would be water supply issues or
traffic congestion issues and so IBM as
part of our corporate branding in
position is that there's a lot more that
we can do to support all of these and
another example and I was going to use
at the end but let me give it now so we
have a IVM volunteer program where I can
go into the system and create a
volunteer opportunity for others at
within IBM to sign up and do and i just
created one within the system of the
last two weeks to take advantage of an
opportunity here in the city of portland
so one of the realities in portland from
an educational point of view at the high
school level and how many people would
guess the data the high number of high
school and teachers that can teach
computer science in the city of portland
how many of you would say 10 or
pretty good how many would say one
that's the right answer one so this is
something that we're working with the
technology association of Oregon Tech
Oregon to create a program to work with
high school students so I'll next
Saturday March 18 if you want to come
and volunteer or be a part of it there's
an opportunity for anybody that's
interested in helping build stem schools
skills in Portland schools to volunteer
and again that it'll be at their
information about that in my twitter
feed but i think there's another
opportunity about volunteerism right so
IBM is helping foster IBM verse to
volunteer I don't want to stop there I
think anybody that has cares about
Portland kids and cares about education
there's an opportunity for you to be a
part of that to help make that happen so
that week as experts can be mentoring
kids and helping the suit schools
overcome the reality that there's only
one computer science teacher in the
whole city all right um any other
questions all right next all right so
I'm going to go in some more details on
four roles here so data scientist and
next slide please all right so the data
scientists I to me this is the the
curiosity position position right it's
like you approach every day of what
going in about what questions can I ask
how can I help my company or my
government or it succeed at doing
something that they weren't doing before
and this is the discipline that
incorporates a lot of different skills
incorporate some of the literacy and I
talked about about data and
understanding data to strategy you need
to understand the governance of data you
need to understand ethics at a basic
level it may not be your day job but you
need to know those basics you need to
understand all four areas of analytics
from descriptive to predictive too
prescriptive to decisive right so these
are if we we've been done a lot of work
over the last three years to kind of
give more precise definitions
each of those four areas a number of IBM
schools that we're partnering with that
the business level are actually building
their programs around those four
concepts knowing how to visualize data
but what really differentiates the data
scientists from my view from a business
analyst is that the data scientists are
going to have to be hardcore techies in
a way they're going to have to
understand especially with today's
technology they're gonna have to know
how to program a computer how are they
going to do a MapReduce job how are they
going to use mahout to do smack machine
learning how did that hottie they can do
book data mining they're going to have
to understand lots of basics about the
technology and be able to actually code
and do it we may get to the point in a
few years where the tools get developed
for the data scientists so it becomes
more of an apply job but today these
jobs are very much hands-on you better
know your stuff from a deep technical
level they do take use of what's there
so we're seeing a lot of emerging job
titles data scientists decision
scientist analytics special this
predictive model ER we're seeing people
emerge with fields and data
visualization so if we go up to
Vancouver not the media one here but
Vancouver Canada so there's a school
there Simon we're getting the last day
and part of it yep phrase rewrite
they've got one of the leading programs
in the whole world in visualization and
analytics and what odds are as a core
programs that are creating and starting
to fill the need but there's a few
others out there that are specializing
but building that kind of skill but not
very many but visualization i think is
really important machine learning so in
the mid 90s i was working for a start-up
in wisconsin and one of my co-workers we
both will out team went back to
urbana-champaign to get his ph.d i mean
just recently crossed paths so where'd
he get his PhD in machine learning so
and where is he living he's living in DC
created the data science meetup group
there how many people here use meetup
com as another online way all right a
few
and so he's got a thousand people in the
DC area that care about data science and
every month he's organizing meetups
bringing people interested in the topic
bringing in speakers from google or IBM
or others to come and talk about and get
a discussion going so it really cool
right so we all sudden or careers came
back small world computational
scientists these are just a beginning I
think of all the different types of
titles so we're working with a couple of
schools at two different levels and
actually there's a lot longer I just
using two examples so the Syracuse I
school in New York they've created a
data science certificate program a
northwestern in the Chicago area is
created a master of science and
analytics run out of an engineering
school so these are much more technical
than the business programs that I talked
about earlier any questions alright next
alright so the chief data officer I put
a question mark here on the where these
skills going to come from because so far
I've not seen a program that's really
designed as to create those types of
skills I think their schools that are
close but none that are really saying
that it's our job to create these types
of skills there's a lot of MS and
information systems courses out there or
your first job might be a data architect
a data engineer but I don't when I look
at their curriculum I don't see them
addressing the top of this chart I see
them data strategy data policy
governance playa fix those courses are
missing for most schools and that's an
opportunity that IBM was working to help
close with schools like I said that's a
fast growing area and these skills are
going to need every company is in need
of these skills today and they're hard
to find and it's one thing that IBM of
oftentimes happy to provide as a
consulting service but still companies
need these skills themselves next data
policy pros so I've talked a little bit
about this and there's a few schools
that have
pieces of the picture so Dalhousie and
Canada has got pieces Syracuse I schools
got pieces and again a lot of the jobs
that pieces are similar but then the
specializations like you may be more
interested in the life cycle of data so
what happens to my piece of 12
components created to the point that we
destroy it do we understand what's going
to happen or is it something that this
is a piece of information and the
government requires me to keep forever
so I can't delete it or is it something
there's actually laws out there that
force people to delete it immediately
when a certain event happens so Netflix
actually got in trouble for this because
they were not deleting customer data
when they left Netflix turns out there's
a government law that was passed in the
80s that required them to do that who
knew right they didn't know it but they
got in trouble for it data privacy and
security that's a biggie data quality
that's we talked a bit about that and
this morning's meeting that and what
does this data really mean is this
useful data or is it bad data
understanding that is a big part of it
master data management is another big
emerging area and governance that a lot
of companies are IBM selves a number of
products around this but the basic idea
is to create a structure for data and
this is the master data would be as a
good simple example here's all the
products that I sell and make so we know
that I have a product it has this Q it
comes in five different colors 20
different sizes and that doesn't change
but what does change around that data is
how much is in stock at this store how
much is in that warehouse how much is on
the way from the manufacturer how much
is in transit right so that when you
start structuring between master and
then all the other pieces around it
gives you a different way of thinking
about your data and then I covered the
compliance of business rules laws and
regulations is a huge huge need is and
we're going to see more of these laws
being created as everybody wrestles with
what do we do with data what's allowed
it's not allowed or I think there's also
a broader issue around policy at the
government level about what should be
the policies bees what should the laws
be how should the laws change that to do
what we need as society right I think
healthcare is a great opportunity for
this because there's a huge side of one
side that says we got to keep it all
private but yet there's a larger
societal need for it not to be private
right so how do we balance that how do
we make that work and some people will
say we'll just D identify the data and
how many people here understand the
concept or heard of the concept of D
identification how many think it's
possible couple so so here's kind of the
reality so here's an example so eighty
percent of the population in the u.s.
can be identified with three pieces of
information that don't include their
name their social security number or
anything else that you would consider
personally identifying so if I know your
sex I know your date of birth and I know
your zip code eighty percent of people
could be uniquely identified with all
three pieces of information right this
is hard right so the more we try to
pretend as possible they did identify
it's actually amazingly easy to be
identified so what got netflix in
trouble wasn't just that they were
disobeying the law that's what
eventually what got him into trouble as
the fine print but they had
de-identified all this data to run the
netflix challenge they were challenging
people that wanted to see themselves as
a career in data science who could come
up with a better algorithm to recommend
better movies for what you want to see
so they took a subset of their data took
out all the personal information and
then put it out there for everybody to
work with turned out they could read n
tify that data how IMDb they go and look
for similarities between people's
reviews in the internet movie database
and what was in theirs bingo we figured
out who you were
right the identification is really hard
and you know I think it's probably a
research area maybe there are ways to
figure out how to do it you know if I
can there's a famous story in health
care of a an MIT graduate student who
combined the quote unquote de-identified
public public employees health care
database with the voter rolls from
Massachusetts and was able to identify
governor william weld in the database by
crossing over those yeah exactly it's
when you combine that's where big data
changes everything right data you didn't
think would ever cook married together
can be married together and you can
figure out correlations you didn't want
made and that also gets back to us as
much its individual stewards of our own
data what do we really want to have out
there right there sings I i said in the
1980s and internet message boards that
I'm going I'm probably pretty happy that
that information is not out there right
now right because they kind of just
disappeared but now if i said something
like that it's going to get stored in
the freaking Library of Congress forever
right all right next slide data
architects I think I covered a lot of
this is it's really them this is the
chief data officer early in their career
and two different schools are working
with on that or Boston University and
item which is kind of MIT of Mexico and
I think these jobs are very much in big
demand is not quite the job role to some
of the others but I think it's going to
be growing based on what I've seen in
the market we're going to see a lot more
demand for these as well and there are
certain companies out there that are
specializing in building these skills
and the companies that I've see doing
the best job of that are actually the
big system integrators that sit in India
so we pro emphasis Tata there's one
other at the four big ones and what
they're doing what which i think is it
should be instructive all of us sitting
here and say higher first india has the
best
now high school and college level STEM
education in the world so they have a
huge pool of kids that want to study
this whereas we have this problem with
kids don't want to study it right and so
they have always smart kids coming out
with master's degree in computer science
or math or whatever and they that's
their baseline and then at when I sat
down and met with wheat pro cup last
month they go okay so once we hire those
kids we're going to put them on at seven
year roadmap of continual education to
turn them into these kind of roles and
here's what we're going to do from your
one you're to your three or four and the
skills and having those skills and
building that up is a true commitment on
their part and I don't see that I don't
not even an IBM I don't see that all
right i think that is instructed all of
us from a competitive point of view of
thinking about this right it's that
ongoing education and actually having
the structure in place and make it work
next all right this was the help me
build a slide one and now i don't
respect ability to do it here but i
would love to build a slide that for
health informatics that had ohsu and
their the logo and hey we're working
with IBM to address this understand what
are the key skills the common titles and
and when the description of what these
are and this is not an area that i'm
personally expert in but i'm hoping to
to learn from everyone here today so i
think that there's a lot of opportunity
within health and bioinformatics because
there's so much public good that can be
done when these fields and just having a
better explanation of what these are i
could put this in the hands and my peers
across the IBM company so that when
they're working and talking with people
i understand these are the skills of
people are looking for what they need
and we can get a discussion going about
okay so this is what the market we think
the market needs this is what you're
teaching how do we close the gap right
and then OHA see you may not have any
gap I don't know but
I'm a lot of schools when I talk to you
and all the other one a lot of them will
have pieces when we actually look at
what the market needs what IBM needs
what our customers and partners need
they need this they're delivering this
so how do we close that gap all right
any questions so the rest of my talk I'm
going to just go over a quick overview
of something investments that IBM is
making that are available to anyone so
I'm going to go through a bunch of these
quickly some of these I know a lot about
some not so much but it is wanted to
make you aware of them so let's go to
the next slide so we've created an
analytic zone and it's got a community
section in it this is run by our
business analytics business unit the
Cognos and SPSS if you've heard of those
technologies and you can go in and learn
about and interact with people are using
these technologies or how they can apply
it to real world business problems this
is free next slide another one
developerworks so if you're a coder or
any kind of a practitioner and you need
to get information about how to how do I
get this done especially if you use an
IBM software though we do a lot of it
around open source as well and we just
created one we don't we announced this
the beginning april called the Big Data
zone this is all about the technologies
that are emerging around big data so
streams who do mahout all the different
pieces that are part of that an IBM has
a number of product offerings now as
well as a lot of our partners this will
be the place to go and get you know
learn I gotta it's all most of our
traffic this site is actually through
google we put the content out and then
as long as the keywords are right people
find all that takes you to the content
and now there's an article that helped
me solve my problem and we have four
rooms we have a lot of other resources
available later next one the other one
that we've done in partnering with a
number of organizations we've created
big data University so this is a site
where you can go and you can sign up and
then you can start taking online short
courses and not very long about Hadoop
and all the different components around
it for example and just start getting
started with it and the code is
available in the Amazon Cloud that costs
you a little bit of money I can put your
credit card and start using it or you
can download it if you've got a pretty
capable pc the reason i say that is the
hadoop stack is fairly involved and to
really use it you need a pretty
tricked-out pc so the typical pc with
four gigs isn't going to cut it you want
something really well configured if you
really want to use a dupe on your own
personal computer so this site I think
yeah that room yesterday we have 80,000
people so far signed up to take courses
there and so by the end of the year
we're easily going to hit 100 probably
125,000 or more that's just another
great way just to get started in the
basics of using this technology but it
doesn't really cover all the other
things I talked about right it's it's
the technology itself how do I use it
how do i do things but not the bigger
picture of these different emerging
fields next slide datta meghe so this is
one thing that my team does we publish
IBM data mag and IBM data meg is a great
place to come to learn about our
products of course but also a lot of
thought leadership content around
governance big data you can get a nice
view on how IBM thinks about these
topics and help you make I'll come to
your own conclusions this was a snapshot
from last night so you can see the title
article right now is the emerging role
of chief analytics officer which is
another path I didn't even go to in my
presentation because there's a whole
path if I took the business side of it
versus thick technology side of it I
could have a lot more slides we have a
there's a lot of great content in there
and frankly if you want her to write for
this man because we don't pay anything
but if you wanted to write
and you wanted to get your name out
there and start building your own
personal resume right get in contact
with me up afterwards I love that if you
had something that relevant to this
audience that you want her to write
about I'd love to help you get published
and it's it's online so we used to be a
print but prints kind of dead so you
know quarterly print magazine your kind
of limited number of pages the beauty
about online I don't have any page
limitations when the content goes up it
goes up right away and my print magazine
was read by people in the US this
magazine my dice mi did a Google
analytic search my readers come from a
hundred and seventy two different
countries so all of a sudden I went from
a very narrow footprint to a global
footprint just by putting it online next
this is the other one that's relevant
right now to the faculty in the room we
have an academic initiative it gets you
access to our software either for
download or to run through the cloud but
the cloud program requires another
request to get to it because we have a
limited ability to give pass it out
right now but the idea here is that you
go you you enroll as a faculty member
you agree to the terms and conditions
which I think are pretty straightforward
and then you become a member of the
academic initiative and you get access
to the software and two shared
curriculum but it might have been
created by IBM or shared by other
faculty members from around the world
and this is a great way to help us and
all work together collaboratively to
help build the skills that are needed in
them in the broader market next slide so
here's the other one this one is too
late for this year but we opened up a
big deal in analytics faculty grants
program focused on curriculum and we had
92 proposals and we opened it up for I
think 45 days and that time we got 92
proposals from 75 different universities
in 22 different
and there's a list of the different
programs a lot of comp site information
science was at the top business schools
math stats operations research and a lot
of these schools are big name
universities Oxford Carnegie Mellon but
also a lot of smaller schools to apply
it runs that I wasn't really all that
familiar with or overseas schools that I
just wasn't aware of and a lot of
phenomenal proposals i wish i had a lot
of money to give away because given all
that interest and the quality of the
proposals we could really foster right
now i think we're probably 15 of the 92
are going to get an award from idea and
so for ohsu i want you to be aware
because when we open this up again in
early next year be great for you to be
competing for some of those dollars as
well all right next slide this is a not
an easy one to read and this is for the
faculty as well so we've just announced
yesterday the big data and analytics
educational conference it will be in las
vegas.the on november 2nd and 3rd it's a
weekend me to be proceeding ibm's
biggest customer conference so we're
going to bring 14,000 people from around
the world to Vegas to learn about big
data and analytics for a week and on the
weekend we putting together a two-day
event just for faculty the first day
will focus on tutorials about how do you
use the software you want to use our big
data stack or SPSS or cognos or perhaps
even Watson in your courses how would
you know how do you do that and make it
easy the next day it's an event put on
by faculty for the faculty so we're
hosting it but it's your peers that are
around the world they're going to be
providing the content with a peer review
panel and it's all the discussion about
how do we do all the things that we've
just been talking about how do we close
the gaps and get the right programs out
there and I'm really excited about that
because I think there's a lot of
opportunities of tremendous interest as
from those 92 people that submitted
proposals asking for money to help build
curriculum
and so I I gave by debe a copy of the
call for papers and she's getting it out
to people and if you didn't get it just
ask her for it or he can ask me for a
copy as well all right next slide I've
got two slides on the visualization
initiatives coming out of our business
analytics team so one is called rave and
it's a kind of a core technology ability
and i'm not expert in these at all just
wanted to provide them as examples so
rave and the one after it many eyes you
want to just show them that as well are
just two online data visualization sets
of features that IBM is making available
for people to work with and if you're
interested in the visualization aspects
I encourage you to go to these sites and
dive in to see what's there because I
think visualizing data is a huge need
and understanding what really works and
what doesn't i think is hard I've seen a
lot of visualizations people go it looks
great but I I sit and stare at it for an
hour I still have walked away I don't
understand what you're trying to tell me
so I think there's a lot of opportunity
the users to type a technology with the
right skill to be able to convince
people of things but I don't think it's
easy let's see what's next I think we're
going to Watson yeah so I've got four
slides here on Watson so I'm not an
expert in Watson but Watson is being
applied to healthcare now by IBM and so
it's not just can I go in jeopardy but
can I use the same technology that was
used to in jeopardy to help doctors and
nurses make better decisions I i think
there's huge opportunity there and so
does the Watson team so it's all about a
lot of different technologies coming
together temporal reasoning statistical
paraphrasing geo spatial reference tax
answers a lot of things that they can
bring together using in this case
patient data to come up with what's a
better answer for what I should need to
do
and what what it might be my next step
space if you can see that all that
history from a lot costs a lot of
different patients and help a doctor
more quickly come to a treatment plan
for example next slide I guess is a
little bit automated sorry just keep
going alright so yeah so it's natural
language and human speech it's
evaluating hypotheses and adapted in
learning right that's what's really cool
about it is that it's not just a search
engine right it's the fact that it's got
some machine learning type ideas the
cognitive in algorithms built in so that
it's learning from itself all the time
and learning how to create better
answers next there's an example at
wellpoint so so that means is this
they're using Watson insights ninety
percent of the time because it's so much
better than what they had before I think
that is really cool and then being
aggressively passing it out so they have
so far they've got six hundred thousand
pieces and medical evidence and two
million pages of text and medical
journals all brought into together to
the system to be able to combine all
these different data points to help them
make better decisions right so then on
this pilot they brought in a lot of test
case scenarios lot of real-life cases
and then 15,000 hours of hands-on
training with mostly put the nurses
helping feed information into what's and
help teach it right I think that's
pretty amazing what this type of
technology can do in an area that's a
very important societal important i
think i might have one more slack so i
think i talked a bit about this right
deep linguistic analysis it can go in
understands many more specific
attributes of patron citizens of
physiology family history genetics right
all of these and classical approaches
are relied on the very explicit rules in
this case you know they're talking about
the rules are lesson
not so brittle that because they've got
all these different things together they
can kind of figure ings out better and
draw better insight and be more current
right because they're immediately
feeding in all the latest research which
there's so much of it being generated is
no way any one researcher can be up on
everything else so there what I like
here is it's that kind of the closing
statement right new disease coverage and
training is accelerating building on
prior knowledge and linguistic adaption
so I'm not an expert in Watson I just
wanted to bring this to you as an
example of how an IBM invention is it be
me immediately applied to something of
great importance of all of us so um so
that's my talk I'm really want to take
questions I want to learn from you and
the rest of this time and appreciate the
opportunity to come
anyone
hi my name is Benita I'm a first year
student of clinician firm Alex with dr.
Phil dodge my question is like somebody
who is not a comes from a computer
science background how can they get an
entry into the antics field what the
skills that they're coming from computer
science not from computer science I
think what if you want to get started
you don't have a computer science
background you absolutely are going to
have to be able to have the mathematical
skills and ability to understand all the
different aspects of stats and I've like
all those different four categories of
analytics that I talked about you don't
have to be a computer scientist to do
that the computer science aspect though
is going to be needed if you really want
to be on the forefront of data science
okay but can you be in analytics and use
apply to analytics without that skill
absolutely right but either way you're
going to need some pretty deep skill
that that's based on a strong stem
background right if you don't have that
it's going to be really hard to get into
this
I your growth rates are definitely
impressive but what's the end are you
starting pervasive one or two hundred
for a cheap date update officer um yeah
those are good questions and I didn't
pull those that got that data from
indeed so they're not huge but they're
definitely yeah quite a few but I we can
talk about that later I don't have the
data pull for companies you work with
what percentage would you guess just of
a gut feel have a date officer ten
percent or they know they may have a
different title for them they might not
be using that title exactly but people
that come to work every day worrying
about those things it's definitely
growing anyone else about some of these
roles do you think that do you think
that these rolls are in addition to the
various chief technology chief medical
information and other officers that we
have or do you think that the needs and
skills need to be kind of reshuffled and
re partitioned into these different
kinds of titles in these different roles
so i guess the basic question is do we
need additional officers to fulfill
these roles because we because the roles
we have are still current or are these
skills that should be combined with some
of the other roles and then kind of
maybe redistribute and retitled yeah um
no that's a really good question and
then in certain fields it may already
kind of have the roles they have a
different now different name to it but i
but I what I think is going to happen
has to happen is just as we all climbing
this ladder and I think what you're
going to see is right now the core
skills that we need aren't quite there
but schools are rushing especially on
the analytic side to build those skills
and over time you're going to see the
basic core knowledge of expectation
rising and the
the higher it rises the more there's
going to be the need for kind of these
people that can really think at an
organizational level about how do we
manage all of that and one thing that
we've seen a fair amount that IBM's
helped create them is we recommend that
large companies a medium large companies
that can afford it they create center of
excellence a--'s around analytics around
warehousing big data and oftentimes it's
really hard to find a person they can do
these jobs but you can find you can
build teams to do it right but you still
have to have somebody that can run that
and understand the broader scope and but
that's going to come over time and you
start thinking about what are all the
different things that might be on a data
science team right so you might end up
with the data steward and data policy
guy you may end up with somebody that
knows that industry you're in really
well bringing industry skill to the
table there may be somebody that
bringing simply project management
school to the table right so i think the
teeming approach is how most companies
organizations are going to solve it and
at the educational level there's been a
lot of discussion about at the Masters
level what are you trying to create are
you trying to create the lap time here
that the Tito did the t-shaped
individual where they have this core
knowledge and depth of knowledge and
skill but then the tea is actually
teaching them how to work with other
people and how to make affect change and
I may I made an argument in a speech
last year that maybe what we need is the
pie-shaped of individual where that
third leg of that is actually more
applied knowledge to the industry that
you're in right that actually is not
just that you know how to do the
technology really well and it's not just
that you know how to work with other
people but you know actually how to
apply it to a particular problem set and
have deep skill in that and I think
that's probably not really realistic so
I think the team approach is really more
likely to be the answer quick follow-up
have you seen
where would that team live
organizationally or I guess in the
successful situations you've seen where
have they lived who have they been under
in terms of yeah well I think if the
more you try to hide it when some
companies do that it's like it's a group
over in the corner the the less likely
the companies are going to be successful
because data as strategy and the impact
of bad decisions or even the impact
negatively your corporate reputation are
so dire that you have to elevate that
organization to sit and be in a place
where it's they're not NIT they're not
in the business I kind of got to sit in
between and that's why we're seeing
these new emerging roles where these
titles are actually in the CC right in
some students and some companies where
it's analytics is uber important now
there's a chief data scientist sitting
on the board right I don't think a lot
of companies won't need that but they
will certainly will have a chief data
officer that has those people working
for them to example or a chief analytics
officer and I think it'll be interesting
to see they'll will the chief data
officer and the chief analytics officer
were those concepts no diverge and be
separate or where they come together and
be one that's to be seen um you know few
a few years ago there was a big push it
seems to kind of died down for this
notion of professional science master's
degrees psms and there was actually
pushing Oregon and we were a little bit
involved in the discussion but so you've
kind of indicated that there's lots of
different fields information science
informatics whatever that can feed this
some but then there's also the issue of
the type of the degree you know the PhD
you know what one one of the problems is
that a lot of science faculty want to
create people that look like them and
become researchers
and and there's a complaint in fact at
the National Institutes of Health now
there's a big push towards looking at
other careers for biomedical scientists
besides academic faculty so is one
possibility almost like the data
equivalent of a professional science
masters that that not only teaches
people the the hard science but the the
soft skills and some of the other kinds
of things that enable them to function
in industry environments right yeah no I
think you're absolutely right and so we
need an ecosystem that covers all of
those right so if we don't have the
strong research basis then now this is
we're not going to keep advancing right
but we also need to have this the skill
that actually able to apply this into
meaningful problems and right now we're
short on both right and like i said
earlier right on the business side the
business schools are it's hard to find
really is hard to find a business school
that doesn't already have an analytics
program that they've announced there
isn't planning to announce one soon and
that's not really going to be a problem
with that finding people with the
business skills to actually understand
how to apply analytics to their business
but when i look at those programs and a
little bit closer some of the things i
talked about are not really prevalent
yet so no data at strategy i oftentimes
is not is missing right so that broader
picture about how do we strategically
manage data or can i create a new
company it's solely based on managing
data right or the whole data policy area
for example another one that i think is
a going to be a gap for a long time and
we it's something that has huge import
to all of us because if we do that wrong
and we get embarrassed or you end up
getting arrested or right and you don't
want that so anyone else back
yeah absolutely and what I by the way
that I'd like to see for i know i don't
know that company personally but icon
Allah side so we've created this
opportunity where two companies owned
all the public data and access to public
data which is the result of all the
different judicial decisions and things
right and there's certain things like
that where I I question whether the
right thing going forward is to allow a
private company to own access to public
data and so I think there's going to be
lots of interesting policy decisions
that have to be made right so should
government even they've ever allowed
West to exist right i mean there are IBM
customers i gotta maybe not watch that
but but there's a reality though that
that is something that's a that's open
to me that's open data that's what
government is about right providing
better services to our citizens and then
if you want to create a service on top
of that that's cool right but you don't
actually own the data i do you do we all
do anyone else i was just going to say
that's especially pertinent in in health
care you know like for example
pharmaceutical clinical trials i mean
those are people who take part you know
yet that data is all at least our
approach to it right now is all
proprietary but there's actually and
there's actually a lot of conversation
about making clinical trials data more
open although by the same token you get
into the privacy issues yeah i think
it's it's it's very significant all
right and it's something that we're
going to all have to wrestle with right
it kind of reminds me of the
conversations in the old Star Trek right
now good for the one are good for the
many right now those are the decisions
that we as a society are going to need
to decide all right thank you again yeah
so the slide aight so as I'm leaving if
you want to follow me on twitter or DC
the things i talked about brand Steve so
my name is not Brandt so brand has to do
with my marketing persona so I brand
Steve so
and you can go you can follow me or at
least you can just see that access to
the those different things in the last
day the volunteer opportunity important
schools how to take advantage of the
call for papers and anything else that
I'm talking about ready to big data so
thank you